[Music]
how do you think about competition and
i'm leaving that very broad or could you
tell us a story about competition either
will do i'm just curious and this kind
of comes back to one of my original
questions
of
whether or not you
have to change your playbook or opt out
of certain competitions
given you have this north star
of
playing nice
about winning
well there are certain kinds of things
that you just opt out of because you're
not willing to play dirty
and i say you see some of that in in
certain countries around the world i
won't name any in particular but you
know who i'm talking about
and so we kind of avoid those things and
you know for me competition is
interesting and often
motivating i think also it can be
limiting
if you're comparing yourself to
competition the competition might not be
very good
you could totally be setting the wrong
benchmarks right if you're measuring
yourself against
you know a competition that's that's not
really that great
and you can also learn a lot about what
not to do from competition
right
but i actually think
it sounds kind of kind of trite or
quaint you know
you learn a lot more from your customers
than than you do from competition and
you know we always talk about having big
ears and
designing the company from the customer
back and
solving the unsolved problems of
customers you're not going to get those
things from from the competition
as as much as you will from
a real understanding of
what the customer is trying to do
you